this is the new camouflage pattern
for the Dutch soldiers
and that looks slightly different
than what they used to wear
because this was more 1 spotted pattern
and to make it clear
here you can see the difference between the old
and the new pattern
has defense in collaboration with tno
worked on this for over 10 years
because it was time for 1 new and modern uniform
therefore also 1 new print
and that is slightly more graphical
with some more blocks instead of 1 kind of spots
and in addition to this green print there are also several
variations
here you see 3 different variations
there is also one for it in snow areas
it is a bit lighter
and here you see the green and the blue together